hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on fallen or again today
we're back with the arcade quest this
one is gonna be called animus redacted
live for chapters as is the other ones
does welcome initiate you've been
selected to synchronize with the past to
protect our future find your target and
eliminate him you know you will know
when you have found him very simple
we're gonna hop in use jayjay of course
just in case to be getting new a gank
situation and we'll see how this goes
I'll see you inside so first up we
already are starting out with three
people i have heavy attacks knock the
opponent back I have uninterruptible on
all moves what I do less damage they not
coming back on heavy attacks land and
their attacks do more damage but they
cannot parry and their and new show
specifically isn't is immune to regular
throw attempts so I can't throw up her
and then JJ deals a [ __ ] ton more damage
on his health as well
alright so big combination I'm gonna I'm
curious how this is gonna you know this
gonna play out
ah [ __ ]
Wow dude I'm actually impressed oh my
god I'm so impressed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I don't know what though [ __ ] I
just did that was not the way any of
that should have went so I found out
that there was spike traps restart so I
went to that I threw the JJ in the whole
plan was to throw the JJ in and then
possibly the Shaolin but it all didn't
go as planned it was not the plane at
all conk of course has a single
consumable shield and knocks Tama home
nearby opponents and I Nev ensued with
LA bring her head I didn't want to
[ __ ] deal with that
you [ __ ] prick
we're not doing this again brother
hi this is another ledge fest
oh my god just [ __ ] fall off already
Jesus oh my goodness he didn't want to
fall off yes
that was easy that's the legend I don't
even really I don't even know what hat I
don't even know whether la bring her had
I was just trying to legend chapter 3 we
fought a ken say that is immune from
regular the throw attempts he respawns
we have a warden that blinds to me from
a heavy attack and a Raider that does
block damage more block damage and they
all respawn regenerate health constantly
revenge builds faster this is a standard
typical 3v1 me trying to be the
anti-gang scenario which is why I pick
JJ this is gonna be interesting if I can
do that
all right easy all I had to do is get
three of them to fight me I didn't
really understand how fast the rear
I think the respawn time was so I was
not taking a chance of it I just said
[ __ ] it we're gonna go right to Raider
and we're gonna 3v1 this whole team
because I have the confidence that all I
need to do is parry and just press the
zone blood that was it and it can end
the cannons help because they were
targeting me which in turn targeted
their team and now I get to fight
let's do and he's buff to max out the
tax deal more damage and he's
uninterruptible very similar to Cesare
from last time except I don't know what
he's gonna play right now I don't know
if he's gonna be like with like T on D
or whatever weapon is he had oh my God
he's Centurion okay that's interesting
he's Centurion thank you
confirmed damage as always yeah not
cheap
Oh off my boost
all case forgetting is the
uninterruptible bob should have done a
heavy and [ __ ] up
can I throw him this I can do the big
damage and [ __ ] Clapton so I just got
inducted into the temple arts because of
this and that was it that was the Arcade
Mode
um yeah that was actually pretty quick I
they said that this was gonna get harder
and harder every time and I do believe
them this was getting harder on off it's
just because I'm playing Jay Jay the
[ __ ] anti gank Queen all right I I
know I said Queen but I don't know if
like it's cuz I'm playing him or
something but this this really wasn't
that bad
I will admit the first one there was a
lot of attempts made in the first one
with the spike trap because getting them
into the supply trap was a [ __ ] other
than that that was probably the hardest
one the rest of this is pretty smooth
sailin the third one is all about
parrying the second one is all about
legend and the fourth one is how well
you could fight a Centurion and survive
it it's really simple stuff hey guys
like the V if you do enjoy subscribe
before knew I should have a video up
later today as well which has to do with
Ezio and Cesare so something a little
different so you could expect that later
oh yeah thank God for watching the video
love you all I like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe for new I covered the
informational side a foreigner that
being balanced changes here are updates
patch notes leaks all that [ __ ] and with
that my team or series of videos would
be on the screen if you guys do want to
check that out and the guys have a very
straight thank you for watching the
video peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]